[Music]
are we allowed to swear
can you hear us are we live are we live
we should probably
uh i wonder if we switch to the wi-fi
right now if it would be all right
can we switch off the wi-fi yeah well
let's see what happens
are you guys there can you we have
it says here we have zero viewers john
that's messed up
oh they can hear us oh it's weird we're
getting comments
yeah maybe the youtube refresh that
this now the other one the youtube one
maybe it just needs to catch up or
all right cool but i'm glad that y'all
are here shouts out
let's see anissa and ryan there we go
okay it's starting to work sorry about
that guys i was like
what the hell we're getting comments but
it's just we have zero people watching
us
cedric pelletier oh they're okay whoa
everything's coming in all at once all
right peter grindall jack
paulie mr dicktovich god of rent
the rent is too damn high yeah that's
true
all right guys we're gonna keep this one
simple today going to keep this one
simple today it's just going to be
favorite comic book movies
all right who's on the chat um i already
donated okay well my girlfriend said i
already donated baby
um so basically right now my girlfriend
actually she just got back uh from a
black lives matter protest
uh i just donated a few hundred dollars
uh to
black lives matter and it's in honor of
everything that's going on in the world
right now
i don't like my politics and my light
well
yeah i don't like seeing it everywhere
on social media everywhere we go
relevant things in my day to day but
we're just gonna let's just keep it fun
today uh to get our minds off of things
but yeah i would like to encourage
people uh
if you haven't um donated or if you're
considering doing it
with everything going on with after the
george floyd incident to go ahead and
donate
and i didn't want to encourage people
unless i did it myself so
guys go ahead and make sure to do that
um
but yeah i figured today this is a topic
that's been requested so many times of
just doing like something simple a
favorite comic book movies and i figured
why not let's just have some fun
it's been a heavy week for a lot of
people like carter's saying right now
riots are going on in his hometown it
got pretty crazy in downtown l.a today
so let's just we're here today to help
you guys just
slightly decompress for uh the next
hour or so knowing our luck we'll see
what happens
by hour we mean next three hours yeah no
let's say
for a solid 90 minutes to two hours
today
but to notify to help you notify people
about the stream
uh can you guys uh just make sure to hit
that like button because it helps people
it helps people uh get notified about it
in their notification bells it's kind of
a weird
algorithm system right now if we happen
to check and it turns out that we have
hit 300 likes
yeah share another surprise but let's
see what's in the comments right now for
your favorite comic book movies we got
batman89 of course that's a
classic one right there that movie
actually i went once to a
an indiana university special
presentation
uh with the guy who like helped fight
to uh get their like first graphic novel
uh
course in stated and part of the the
huge dam breaking of that was that
original
batman movie like a lot even i think
they even helped get that made too so
hey jenna randolph thank you so much my
dear
jenna randolph she says yo what's up
i love you guys work is going good one
of my favorite superhero movies are
avengers and the cartoon justice league
as well as the teen titan ones
i mean those are obviously great picks
right there avengers
um oh man do you remember the first time
you saw avengers
i was like they [ __ ] did it all those
complaints that happened
with all those phase one setups just
went
right out the window and was like worth
it we got here
absolutely worth it everyone's beef with
iron man 2 was then
alleviated yeah no it really was though
um the cartoon justice league movies are
great i mean the
dark the dark apocalypse one i hear is a
[ __ ] incredible yeah i've been
hearing about all week
so i if you guys have hbo and
in the united states you should get
automatically up thank you jenna i
really appreciate that dear
if you guys have uh hbo in the united
states you should get automatically if
you're
subscribed directly to them through them
i don't know if i said that right
you should be able to get uh hbo max
automatically
and i uh the first thing i watched two
movies this week on hbo max
and this one was like you know what [ __ ]
let's make it our topic because neither
one of these are my favorite comic book
movies
but i watched two comic book movies the
first one i watched was lego batman
movie
and i saw that in the theaters but
honestly i
i was a major pothead at the time and i
couldn't keep up with any of what was
going on in the movie and especially the
time i got to that finale
i was like there's so much happening
this is so much chaos and i have no idea
what's happening
okay um but i really loved it i highly
recommend watching it sober i'm not one
of those guys who's ever been able to be
high in absorbent animation i just so i
start getting uh
i start getting really bad racing
thoughts and
but the other one i watched i finally
saw this movie
not one of my favorites for sure finally
saw for the first time can you guess it
is it gonna be i think i know it is is
it one of my favorites
nope nope it's not oh i don't even think
you've seen it it's green lantern
yeah ah that's definitely not the one i
know you watched recently i was going to
name it i
finally decided to watch green lantern
wasn't as bad as i
expected it to be it's pretty it was one
of those moves where i'm like with just
some slight
like uh if you if you cut out some stuff
and you restructured certain things and
you focused in a little better
this could have been a really really
cool film
but the execution overall is a big part
of what led it down big time nah
yeah that it just felt like is the the
one thing i hate
like because the movie fluctuates
between
um so bad it's entertaining to
um annoyingly bad to boring bad
you know oh boring that's the worst and
boring yeah because it just could feel
starts feeling like plain and hollow
and uh but you know just like waiting
for scenes to wrap
up but weirdly what i'll say is peter
sarsgaard is my
actor who i irrationally hate i just
can't stand the guy
for some reason and i surprisingly
walked away going
he wasn't that bad is one the most
entertaining part
of the green lantern movie see there's a
silver lining yet to be fair
also uh uh who is that judas i say at
least
unless you have a gripe uh yeah we can
include manga in fact uh
riccio the story of ricky has been uh
described to me a number of times so i
would love to see the movie at some
point i i actually have a friend
what's up rachel if you're watching um
who i used to work at uh universal with
who like was dying to see that uh
manga and movie become a like a haunted
maze or something like that but
it's a good it's a good call out carter
lovejoy my f
thank you carter so kind of youtube um
my favorite comic book movie of my
favorite films of all time list is v
for vendetta yeah i i like that picnic
and i wish um uh uh
oh my god alan uh more i wish alan moore
would watch that movie because i feel
like he might actually enjoy that film
or at least not hate it actually the one
i really wish alan moore would
check out is the watchmen hbo series
because it's not following any of his
work that he did i mean it's following
in the footsteps of his work
but i really think it actually in a lot
of ways captures the spirit and honor
i feel like he might be a little bit
happy with that one i know he seems like
a really hard guy to satisfy
with so many of these things yeah i mean
i think he maybe it has chilled out a
little bit over the years at least in
terms of his
uh vehemence against them but he strikes
me as one of those guys who's just
not interested uh i saw scott pilgrim
we're seeing a lot of love for scott
pilgrim versus the world in here
uh and i saw that recently i enjoyed it
that was fun i do love the scott pilgrim
myself
the rocketeer i've studied up on for
inner geekdom fights but i have not seen
the rocketeer yet
um let's see here spider-man 2 it's
probably spider-man 2 still my favorite
spider-man movie if i'm being totally
honest hey guys if you're just jumping
in make sure to hit that like button
we're just getting warmed up right now
um but yeah i would say spider-man 2
still my favorite one of the spider-man
films and then i would say spider-man
into the spider-verse
okay all right rizzo gaming ryan
beatty back with a vengeance let's see
let's see here and then i want to start
talk after ryan's uh he has a few here
after his i want to start talking about
some more underrated comic book movies
or comic book movies that
uh we might not even realize our comic
book movies i just watched one
oh yeah i'm interested to hear what it
is hey guys thank you ryan beatty tdk
guardians of the galaxy kick ass hey
you're a matthew vaughn fan
x-men first class logan deadpool 2
iron man all four avengers films and
watchmen into the spider verse my top
ten those are all solid picks right
there i mean the dark knight
[ __ ] monumental guardians of the
galaxy age of ultron
age of ultron he listed all four
avengers movies
i don't know if i can meet you on
watchmen but i would i
i do prefer deadpool 2 over deadpool 1
and ironman
instant classic of course and into the
spiderverse we need more films like that
i think watchman i'll give you watchmen
in the sense that even if the movie
doesn't completely get there
there's there is a lot to appreciate and
i just saw a pretty great uh wisecrack
video about that movie and it's sort of
approach as compared to the comic book
that made me kind of appreciate it a
little bit more
you know and of course of course scott
pilgrim
honorable mention scott pilgrim was it's
a fascinating film
thank you again for that ryan beatty
it's a fascinating film because scott
pilgrim
did not make a lot of money but it's
become this like cult hit
and it's constantly brought up in the
inner geekdom showdown match
so i was like i feel like i need to
watch this you know well that was one of
the rare ones where it didn't do very
well but universal was still like
no we're proud of this you know which is
nice you see
what i'd also add on to that is spawn
spawn was not well received by critics
did not make a lot of money at the
theaters but spawn is uh
that a lot of people have really
championed for that film
and blade trinity there's a lot of
people talking about blade in here
and blade trinity is so underrated
hannibal king ryan reynolds that's where
deadpool was really born
i'm of course joking guys don't take me
seriously on that no
crack craig lastly hey man is the first
time i think i've ever seen you in our
super chats or in our live streams
before thanks for thanks for being here
dude it's a sexy photograph which one
did he list john
he listed spider-man into the
spider-verse
which i mean it's it's totally hard to
argue with that's a terrific
terrific motion picture and in a time
where there's so many superhero flicks i
feel like that was one that really gave
us
like a breath of discovery again and
sort of like fresh air in terms of like
wow the possibilities oh yeah of course
oh yeah that's a that's a wonderful film
it's a good choice
um hellboy is uh that's
i actually prefer hellboy two over
hellboy one yeah
and this may for me just be because i've
seen hellboy two more times but i i
generally gravitate towards the second
film yeah
one of my especially because like
there's that seth macfarlane character
that yeah
you know i should remember his name he's
one of the few seth macfarlane roles
where i'm like you just really
disappeared into this movie
well that's right my uh
my one of my favorite movies of all time
is actually a graphic novel that i
really want to read which is road to
perdition
just watched road to prediction first
time no no but again like
the first time in a while beautiful this
is a great [ __ ] beautiful
all right like set like such respect for
everybody involved because yeah that
movie is so
you you wouldn't guess it's a graphic
novel but then when you hear it you can
start to piece it back together and i
would love to see what it actually looks
and reads like because
yeah it's such a poetic and such a
it's there's so much life in that movie
you know yeah i can't say enough good
things about it
ellen into the ellen verse jenna
randolph back in here thanks
jenna i oh i own a good bit of cartoon
justice leagues i got justice league
dark
i didn't realize i mean jenna we've
gotten to know each other pretty well i
didn't realize you were into all these
i know you're really an anime but i had
no idea you were into all these other
like animated
comic book movies the geeks what the
[ __ ] jenna yes what the [ __ ] jenna i
thought we knew each other
war flashpoint paradox um
flashpoint paradox oh if you haven't
seen that
yes do it actually when running today
and i wore my flash shirt
and then everyone kept out running me
titans the judas contract and teen
titans versus justice league have you
seen them
i've seen two of these uh but flashpoint
paradox is easily my favorite one that
you listed
here i gotta watch the other ones so
they disappoint me with hbo max they
have this dc section on hbo max
there's like five movies on there yeah
you showed the other five there's like
ten but then five of them are good and
the other five were like
batman and robin and green lantern the
ones where you're like of course you got
the rights to these what a bunch of
[ __ ]
they know these are all great
recommendations and i feel like i think
most of them are on the dc
universe app which i do own actually
so wait does the dc universe app have
more than the dc
no if you want don't get hbo max with
the dc [ __ ]
if you're gonna get hbo max uh you know
get it for doctor get it for fresh
prince of bel-air
friends friends the new looney tunes
shout out to batman under the red hood
that's being shouted out on the chat
right now absolutely
though the comic book movie i grew up on
the most was actually and
and said in the chat just mentioned it
was the crow
i watched that way too many times as a
young lad
it is that is an incredible incredible
film and honestly you know what i think
crow city of angels is an all-right film
i'm just going to say it it's the entire
franchise i think curtis city of angel's
got
terrible feedback from audiences and
critics of life and i think it's all
right i don't mind it
yeah that's that's one of the the stupid
things i want to do someday is like go
and watch all the crows or all the from
dusk's till dawns
verdugo silver thank you so much for do
go
silva dude verdugo here to you
to hugo verdugo which is a street near
us
snow piercer is easily one of my
favorite movies of the decade
also superman 4 for some good laughs he
literally rebuilds the great wall of
china
with his eyes yo the nuclear man fight
versus superman is the most underrated
thing in the world and actually i'll
give you a
thank you verdugo silver for your
contribution here and the another fun
fact i'll give you is
john cryer who plays uh lenny luther in
superman four
he uh he said that he really wanted to
sign on to play lex luthor in the dc
uh universe shows the air over shows
like supergirl mainly
because he sought it as a chance of
redemption for what superman four
actually turned turned out being so we
probably wouldn't have
a pretty i mean it's all subjective but
a pretty decent
you know uh lex luthor on the arrowverse
shows
if it wasn't for superman four so hell
yeah and i hate to admit it i'm guilty
have not
[ __ ] seen snow piercer yet i'm sorry
yeah that's that's forget that's a comic
book based i know i do too
like edge of tomorrow i forget that's
based on a comic book too
but thank you buddy that's a really
great comment right there yeah it's
funny i never forget the first time i
saw superman three
it was in the old jump cut cafe and we
got to watch on 30
on 16 millimeters so all that jor uh uh
all that
yeah all that uh prior goodness
um ooh oh yes thank you ryan beatty and
both hellboy films and be for vendetta
those are solid picks man hellboy one
and two
hellboy three i mean i feel like that's
a chan with the way petitions are
going and how they're influencing i mean
just recently i heard even with the
simpsons on disney plus they
they reformatted it back to its original
4x3 format
that people were mad about when they
stretched it out
and that was from fan outcrying and then
sonic and then of course the snyder cut
they should petition to get hellboy 3
done like a proper hellboy 3.
it might make it might be a guillermo
del toro project that makes a lot of
money
it might be the first yeah it's first
like he's always doing stuff
it's like oh this is beautiful it's got
a great idea not really
breaking in the dough though i mean
yellow flash in the chat is saying tmnt
is a 1990
uh comic book movie well all the teenage
mutant ninja turtles are all comic book
movies technically
your favorite ethan holgate what's up
buddy
um let's see here thank you ethan
holgate absolutely love
lions gates animated marvel movies you
know those don't get enough love
the the marvel animated films they
really everyone talks about the dc anime
but then again everyone talks about mcu
but
dc animated movies i mean mc marvel
animated movies do not get enough love
uh next avengers heroes of tomorrow hulk
versus wolverine which is
ironically my dream comic book movie to
have del toro direct a hulk versus
wolverine movie
also unbreakable and spider-man 2. you
know what i would i would say
unbreakable does count as a comic book
movie in a way in the same way scott
pilgrim i would count as a
as an asterisk video game movie i would
also count unbreakable yeah because it
is so inspired by and indebted to and
about
comics and superheroes that yeah uh
anissa
and this is in the chat michael b in the
chat
um dylan m n pereira hell yeah
you know a lot of there's a lot of
people in the chat saying sin
city right now i was about to say where
is the love for arguably my favorite
comic book movie which was actually also
just one of my favorite memories of us
as young people going to the movies oh
yeah we snuck
we bought tickets for something else and
we snuck in generality too is that what
it was
yes don't worry i eventually watched
miss congeniality too not as good as
missing
only one but but uh yeah sin city sin
city is the perfect movie to watch with
the lights off because once you turn the
lights on when that movie's done
the color in real life really stands out
i wish a dame to kill for was just as
good as the first one
but yeah ah yeah release the snyder cut
thank you michael b cut oh [ __ ] i just
wrote
hashtag release and i just assumed it
was snyder yeah
your brain yes all the all of our
original cuts of the videos need to be
released yes
none of the videos you've seen are our
original cut you know with the snyder
cut it's supposed to cost
probably like probably more than 50
million dollars apparently i'm not at
all surprised and the reported budget
was like 30 initially speaking
so yeah thank you michael b for that
it's gonna cost
stupid money constantine is very
underrated absolutely um you know that's
one of those movies that i miss that i
actually do want to catch up with in the
superhero realm like i feel like that
might be one i would enjoy for its own
merit
ryan beatty back at it man of steel my
favorite superman movie q
flight you know man of steel has been
getting so much love again lately and
i'm so happy for it i
i just don't think you can argue i think
the finale goes on
a little too long i'll admit that but
that first fight with feyora owie
and um i forgot the other guy's name but
the one
in smallville in the town center that
first fight is my favorite fight of the
whole film more than the zod
and big metropolis fight scene that when
the
restaurants are getting destroyed and
[ __ ] that man of steel fight is
incredible i love
like the little details of when they're
like superman's trying to fly away they
keep pulling him back down that's my
favorite part of that fight yeah and and
i mean
um i i really like it's weird
i'm with you i feel like that is like an
underrated dcu
i love the first half like i feel like
yeah the finale is just the second half
of the movie where that fight goes on
for a century
but i really like that take as much as
people don't and as much as i don't love
what it led to
like i think man of steel is underrated
in some ways
it's getting it's it's getting a lot of
praise it's gonna this
this resurgence of praise for man of
steel is gonna lead to the proper man of
steel three
yellow flash it's funny the losers is a
movie i haven't seen but
lately in the past two weeks i have
heard a lot of people claim that that is
an
underrated superhero yeah that's [ __ ]
cool it's really cool
jeffrey d morgan chris evans zoe saldana
hey
it's a movie chris evans man i didn't
even realize yeah
nancy back in the gym back in the super
chat thank you
can't pick between days of futures pass
or winter soldier they're both
so good i would say winter soldier i
would prob
i probably as much as i want to just
play devil's advocate and go days of
future past i feel like
winter soldier might still edge it yeah
such a solid like espionage flick
i feel i mean obviously i think it was
more fun to be had with days of future
past
i mean there was a time where i would
have said days of future pass first but
i'm trying to pander to the mcu audi now
trying to get that marvel paycheck um
guys if you're just tuning in make sure
to hit that like button please but
nancy um because i i watched
funny enough when i first saw winter
soldier i thought it was really cool
when i re-watched it i loved it
days of future past i loved and i really
wanted to show my girlfriend
logan but i was like you gotta watch
dave's future passwords that's also
really great
and then i showed her days of future
past and for some reason i just didn't
like it as much as i remembered
loving it like that quicksilver scene is
so great there's still some great
sequences
but for me this is an easy one uh right
now winter soldier would be my pick
i almost wonder if days of future packs
loses a little something because like
there was a
metaness to the fact that the very setup
of the movie was
also to like fix a bunch of bad
continuity
yeah so i wonder yeah if just like once
that sheen is broken yeah if the movie
is that solid just on its own
i mean la la for logan right now in the
chat hey hilary b welcome to the chat
here
uh have not seen the road cut of days of
future past unfortunately not
yet captain l in the civil war though
damn look at my man's mohawk here you
got a [ __ ] like
you got a uh you got a goddamn thanos
follower name here
yeah yeah yeah you can have a special
black order name dude um
captain america thank you for your super
chat captain america the first avenger
this is a joe johnson flick that john
and i
really disagree on i'm not a fan of that
movie i
i i actually like the first half before
he gets the
super soldier serum and gets hunted down
by heinz kruger
uh i'm i'm i like which i think richard
armitage played him
hines oh my god thorin uh yeah
yeah i break out pretty sure um
yeah i'm pretty sure he did oh man
anywho
um i think you're probably right yeah so
so anyway uh yeah
you like that movie though you really
like first avenger and i i just can't
get on board with like the last half of
it
it's one of those movies that i it's
it's weird when people
tell me that they think it's like not
one of the strongest or they think it's
all right like i actually don't
disagree i don't necessarily think it is
the strongest or even the strongest of
the phase
one but there is something about that
movie and its construction and just the
style of it that i
get really attached to for whatever
reason so yeah i i
do appreciate that movie a lot even if i
will concede
that there are far better qualitative
mcu joints yeah you know my problem with
that movie is
it it's kind of my problem that i have
with public enemies setting it during
world war ii
yeah i'm not a fan of world war ii but
world war one man we don't get enough of
those that's why
captain america no it's it's more
of the fact of like it's not one it's
one of my things that i'm just not a fan
of but the way it's
shot with its like hd cameras
and like you could really you want to
feel like it's on film yeah
whereas like public enemies had that
problem for me where i was like
i'm so aware this is not like it's shot
on hd camera video cameras didn't exist
back then
the movement is all off but i love how
cedric and the chat's trying to get the
uh ellen the ellen chat ellen's coming
back ellen chance back in here
i was gonna say i've seen a couple
people shout out mask of the phantasm i
thought that would get
a deluge two mask of the phantasm
is like classic in terms of like
animated comics
i have i have a dream um
[Music]
i have a dream uh batman and thought not
anthology but batman series i want to
make where he basically starts off as a
younger bruce wayne that arks in the old
man bruce wayne kind of like dark knight
kind of like how aging works kind of
like how aging generally works
and um my i wanted my first one to be
inspired from mask of the phantasm being
at the andrea beaumont character
their rise of the phantasm is what i
would call it um
and yeah i don't say much more cool i
have a
i have a weird question are there any
other comic book series that have
like batman seem special to me because
you have harley quinn who rose out of
the
cartoons and then you have phantasm who
was created for that movie and that's a
well-beloved
movie is there any other like car
comic book or character who has had
characters introduced in other media
that are as well accepted as those and
as well respected as those
you guys in the chat tell them because i
can't think of one right now yeah
i don't know because like mad respect
like every time i'm reminded of the fact
that phantasm isn't just a classic
batman villain i'm like okay
remix 360 plays thank you buddy love
your thumbnail
my favorite anime to watch is sword art
online can hike you
haiku and my hero academia well we'll
meet you on my hero academia buddy
i've heard of sword art online yeah and
uh the title alone is perplexing to me
and speaking of and thank you for your
super chat dude uh i'm gonna use your
super chat as a chance to say like i
haven't covered the attack on titan
season four trailer because
so much of our anime reaction based
videos have got him completely blocked
and we've gotten copyright strikes from
them so it's kind of like scary
territory territory for us to step into
so you don't want to get the channel
shut down over some dumb [ __ ] everyone
knows how
[ __ ] bizarre youtube can be so yeah
that's why but thank you dude for uh
mentioning that too
yes cedric release the air cut that's
what i want well i want the air cut
i do haircut more than this i mean i i'm
excited for the event the snare cut is
but i want to see that air
i mean this might just sound like me
trying to sound cool but my favorite mcu
character is actually
um charlie cox's matt murdock
daredevil portrayal that's great that's
my personal favorite mcu character so
i'm really hoping they keep him around
narosh krishnan thank you dude um
superman the red sun shazam
winter soldier spiderman homecoming
wonder woman
it seems like what i love about yours is
that it's including both dc
and marvel showing that we don't have to
always be
at war i feel like shazam probably would
have gotten a lot more love if it didn't
come out like a week before end game you
know
yeah that's an unfortunate timing thing
or maybe if marvel made it
people would have they did they made
captain marvel uh a month
a month before yeah oh boy captain
marvel's my favorite comic book movie
i'll still say man when i watch wonder
woman whenever i get to that
uh no man's land scene constant tears i
just cannot [ __ ] help it
every single goddamn time it's emotional
uh what else have you seen in the chat
uh yeah i heard uh speaking of michael b
uh you should watch campy's video
he released an essay on man of steel
earlier this week and i've been meaning
to listen to it
um yeah it's all about how there's no
snyder cut it's all it's all about how
henry cavill actually worked out for the
role yeah yeah yeah
robert fans just spitting in the faces
of all the fans
eric horseman our buddy with the real
rejects tattoo thank you so much for
your
major [ __ ] super chat dude um
wonder woman and galaxy quest now cheer
me the f up please
like sequester comic no it's not but
it's based in the comic-con world and
all that it's inspired by the trekkie
fan base and everything like that
there's a great video about galaxy quest
uh a documentary on the fandom
entertainment channel you guys should go
check out that my friend directed
oh that's awesome i had like it i
literally didn't realize until later
that they were the same project because
he was like oh i'm working on a
documentary about galaxy quest
guys if you don't know you might have
heard us mention before it's a real
real rejects tattoo r-e-a-l-r-e-e-l
rejects that too in that order um only
human being
ever get it only human being whoever
will get it uh
make sure that i got uh last week when
we did a live stream he mentioned that
he was actually gonna get
a uh he got a kova 19 test and he was
waiting for the results i thought you're
going to say cover 19 tattoos
trying to get a cobra 19 tattoo
represent the year you know brush across
your face right there
but he uh he actually uh got his test
results back
and he does not have it hey that is
something to feel
better about dude glad and wonder woman
1984 i'm sure will
rock so with that in mind you should
feel better
thank you eric for showing your support
buddy i hope your brain feels okay
um i've heard those tests are unpleasant
let me ask you guys in the chat would
you count the incredibles
as a comic book movie it's based on
superheroes obviously inspired by
characters
who are super already in comic book
medium but would you call it incredibles
a comic book movie
i think that would be an interesting
little mini film festival is honorary
comic book movies that like technically
aren't but
still occupy that same spiritual realm
you know uh i would say a kick ass is a
great con there's a lot of people in the
chat right now who are mentioning
kick ass kick ass is a great comic book
movie
i'm very curious to revisit kick ass
too because i don't i don't recall
really liking it when i saw it in
theaters
however i i keep wondering maybe on a
second viewing i might
like it more i mean did it help that jim
carrey
himself was going out there and not
supporting the movie and
uh maybe he plays uh colonel stars and
stripes in the movies and he
did he does not support that movie
because of the i think it was the sandy
shootings that were happening
yeah and so but still i i keep wondering
like what if
what if actually that movie's good
because there's there's always a lot of
like in this chat there's been a lot of
love for kick ass
but no one ever mentions kick ass too
you know yeah
and it's weird because there are as much
as i again didn't love that movie there
are parts of it and
funny enough jim carrey is one of them
that do really stick out and stay in my
mind
so yeah would be i would be curious as
much as i remember
like actually disliking them
you know it seems like a lot more people
in this chat love superman 3 more than i
realized
um mike pryor boy michael b thank you
buddy
uh man of steel is the best dragon ball
movie
that is the best you know that finally
all right
justin chatwin deserves more respect
justin
fat worked their ass yeah okay the rise
of goku is a masterpiece
um what you know that final fight
between zod and and uh superman
and metropolis to me that is the better
version of what the fight
should have been in matrix revolutions
with agent smith and neo
or bvs because
because when i watched that fight scene
that's what i kept flashing to
and i kept going man this is this seems
like what the wachowskis were trying to
go for in the matrix revolutions yeah
and uh i love like that that fine what's
weird is i can't really appreciate that
whole finale of man of steel in one
sitting because
it's just such a once it starts off
where i mean i [ __ ] love that moment
though when when superman
after uh martha kent is threatened and
he's like just
going through the field and punching sod
i love that scene i feel the emotion
there
yeah but i i can't um i can't honestly
say that it i can always fully
appreciate the entire finale because
it goes on for such a long time but when
you break it up into segments
it's pretty [ __ ] great
i like tarantino's ladies yeah
i don't know in some ways yeah um you
know it's another great
um graphic novel adaptation that
uh i didn't really love until the second
time i watched it
david cronenberg's history of violence
and i read to me that is a great
way to adapt a graphic novel if you
haven't seen
uh if you haven't read the comic and
then watch the movie you'll see there's
a lot of differences there's
similarities obviously but there's a lot
of differences in terms of
it would be smart in the execution of
this to cut
out these scenes that way what we're
focusing on
feels more mysterious and uh history of
violence is another that that one
deserves a lot more uh
respect i don't think a lot of people
realize it's actually a graphic novel
movie
yeah i haven't actually seen the movie
i'd need to it's pretty good man
i know [ __ ] um maria bello and viggo
mortensen have
crazy ass sex scenes in that movie
sexual encounters oh sex
let's all face it the best comic movie
is the snyder cut definitely it's
already
oh goodness i saw oh who was that
somebody called out a comic book movie
and 300 i'm surprised we haven't
spoken at all about 300 yet which uh i
don't know if anyone else has had the
experience
but recently i tried to rewatch 300
on dvd i couldn't do it and three
quarters of the way through it
it like throws the dvd player so i tried
it in another dvd player froze
that player grabbed a different copy of
the disc
and it froze the dvd player too so i
think something about the original dvd
pressing of 300 is meant to destroy your
machinery
so uh the two-thirds though that i got
to see were still uh pretty epic
yeah 300 rise of an empire was
monumental in my
life yeah like yeah it was
we got i got hit up by a pearl weibull
uh who used to represent watching
uh hannah hart on youtube and we were
the channel was like
just a couple thousand a few thousand
subscribers at the time and
i got to go to the red car premiere of
300 rides of an empire wanted me to vlog
it
apparently open up the door for uh
legendary legendary pictures
to work yeah to work with youtube i
didn't know that so they took the chance
of a small youtuber which was me at the
time
that's really cool like that's that i
still vividly remember that never been
invited back
okay what else is it guys you know i've
seen some people in the chat right now
like malcolm spider mentioning jonah hex
i keep wanting to watch john i wanna
watch
key point it's on hbo max i keep wanting
to watch it
is it worth watching because i really
feel like that could be
a great r i've seen like the motion
comics episodes and i think that could
be a
wonderful wonderful r rated western
film in the comic book sphere yeah but i
i keep
really wanting to check out the
supposedly god-awful
josh brolin megan fox-led jonah hex i i
really i'm very curious to check that
one out
i am too partly because one of my i
don't think a lot of the music made it
in but one of my favorite metal bands
mastodon did
part of this yeah they they did the
score and then eventually like
collaborated on what became the like
used score with marco beltrami so
yeah but yeah jonah hex always feels in
the glimpses i've caught of the comic
and the movie i'm like this seems like
one of those that could make a terrific
movie but very easily make
a really bad movie um
eric horseman uh you asked if that a
comic book movie he's saying thank you
for your super chat dude
galaxy quest does have a comic so yeah
yeah that's a little bit of both right
there i didn't know i got to read it now
we thank you for your super chat now we
know a fun fact eric horse that was a
fun fact i feel so
enlightened and also joyous in all
seriousness eric
i love the [ __ ] out of you and you know
that dude i love the hell out of you man
i love the [ __ ] and damn out of you i
haven't seen chronicle yet and i feel
like
right now is the perfect time to go show
support to
to that screen to to max language
and josh right now is the perfect time
oh i thought you'd seen chronicle
i haven't seen chronicle no no not yet
we should watch
it together if we weren't in here
together all week joshua riddle
thank you so much dude here's a photo of
him going to prom
with his mother nah i'm sure that's in
love
blade spider-man 2 infinity war and
i'm sorry i haven't talked about
infinity war at all uh
overpowered by end game now i mean
there's a lot of people who
who wait i mean what do you got in the
chat do you guys prefer infinity war
over end game because i see a lot of
people who say that
i definitely prefer end game over
infinity war
blade though i i
really hope like the mcu sometimes
does if someone played them formerly
they will put
them as a cameo in um
in their mcu rendition they definitely
did with the hulk
um but i i really hope that for the
maharsha ali
blade film that we do get a wesley
snipes cam
i just keep wondering if it's gonna be
like too distracting because it's
[ __ ]
like a lot of times with these cameos
you you don't realize like it's like lou
ferrigno or something
you don't realize oh that was the former
person
yeah i feel like with wesley snipes
everyone's
yeah unless they make him some kind of
character and hide him a little bit
but yeah you know it depends yeah you
don't want him to be unrecognizable
obviously
speaking of not a not a comic book movie
but last night i rewatched two wong
fu which has a great drag performance
from
wesley snipes as well as swayze and john
leguizamo well that's fun to hear
yeah uh let's see here
god there's there's uh you know what you
know what
a lot of people forget is a comic book
movie is the men in black franchise
yeah i'm never first one's great i've
never
even seen a panel on like online of what
an
anime what the comic looks like but i
mean the cartoon
but now i'm very curious to go look up
whether or not
um it uh like what what the differences
are
yeah what if you go and watch it and
you're like or look up you know some
current of some panels and you're like
this doesn't look anything like the
movie i mean 99
of the time when you look up those
differences especially with those
earlier comic book movies you find out
they were
way more edgy than before like spawn
surprisingly i
i forgot this spawn director's cut
was the first director's cut film i'd
ever seen probably outside of
terminator 2 special edition because
spawn is
like is totally an r-rated source
material but
but they had to tone down the violence
to get a pg-13 rating
um but the director's cut is that is a
case of
like that's better you know because
because you're gonna be like
r-rated what is this mother russia is
this uh is this a
what's mother russia i know about yes a
few people mentioned it
dude we get to see chase gardner's face
chase garner
chase gardner is constantly in our
patreon
and he's been a long time patrons
annoying stop yeah stop
supporting us on patreon oh thank you so
much
and it's the first time i've seen your
face comic book movie logan favorite tv
show arrow
[ __ ] yeah man i love both of you i've
seen out of all the dc
shows live action arrow is the only one
i've seen
all the episodes of yeah love me some
stephen amell
he's the kind of guy i wish i could be
and logan
logan is perhaps there's a very strong
argument to be made that
logan is the the best of them all like
the best of them all i mean it
definitely
crosses into a different caliber of
film to me anyway oh god you know such
that's so [ __ ] good logan is like
even to this day
so many things it's not like age poorly
or anything yeah
it's still so [ __ ] good it's a
satisfying and cathartic drama
western comic book movie all of the
above
you know and every element of that is is
served you know
uh but arrow i i wasn't a fan of the
last step
i'm not gonna lie and i honestly i i've
had michael b
who's been in our super chat on our
patreon um he
he he was actually we've gone back and
forth on this
in the dc crossover crisis on infinite
earth of how
um uh oliver queen spoilers john i know
you're planning on watching
all eight seasons as long as it's not
the season finale of black lightning was
season one
the way oliver and i'm gonna not spoil
anything the way oliver queen's
conclusion goes
in crisis on infinite earth the final
episode
wasn't a fan of what they did with
oliver queen i thought it was very
cheesy honestly some people really love
it and i just did it but hey does he go
listen to the remember
yeah he lives out as a lumberjack he
leaves his kid behind
yeah and it's purgatory and then he cuts
the black yeah
before you know what happened to him
every disappointing
series finale you've ever seen yeah and
uh this was also he could ask to date
your aunt
uh let's see here this is cake town
oh i haven't seen that goofy trailer in
so long the 300 trailer parody but thank
you for bringing that up who
who's ever did that oh my god dude
agoraphobic fanboy i love your hair by
the way adore your whole face
thank you for this comment i i really
appreciate this dude thank you for this
yes your hair does look like paul from
tech and diet blonde
this is an opportunity the animated tmnt
sequel
everyone forgets is sort of underrated i
completely agree with you hi
it was panned by critics i saw it in the
theaters
i thought it was a badass ninja film
and i love the action in it i honestly
don't remember like the story or what
really happens
in terms of plot but i really remember a
lot of the action and yeah
i gotta say i'm really glad you brought
that up because the animated tmt film is
pretty [ __ ] great if you guys haven't
seen
it give it a shot and you're right it's
com it is forgotten we remember
teenage mutant ninja ninja turtles one
two three and remember
the recent renditions tmnt the animated
movie is better
than the last two recent editions of uh
the michael bay produced films i'm
gonna put that out there right now if
you guys are new hit the like button by
the
way
and i think there is a small consortium
of people who do share this opinion
i've actually i've heard i've been given
stray recommendations for tmnt a few
times lately
did somebody say mystery men
miss i've i actually never got to see
myself fired by confidence
entirety yeah uh let's see
here let's see here okay i mean just
some obvious ones for us like
joker is uh i love the beginning and the
finale of joker i'll say that
i love the experience of watching it in
context
and also this is more common than than
lately
my i don't know how many people i'm
gonna set by saying this batman returns
i prefer over batman 1989.
i'm just saying this is a character arc
i feel like you need a stars in the chat
what's up dear hi
nina oh hello i feel like yeah dude have
you
have you sort of grown love for that
movie over time
uh batman returns yeah i didn't like
when i was a kid but as i as i've
read when i really watched uh all four
films
batman returns was like actually i i
think i
love this way more than oh damn 89. all
right yeah
that's just my opinion i love this
yellow tranq or yellow flash josh track
bought the studios to get miles teller
in
fantastic four only to try and fight him
i haven't thought about that random
andy's channel how you doing buddy
uh great to have you back in here just
sending love wish i could be here y'all
rock well thank you dude
sending the love right back at you are
things going okay right now please let
me know man
um don't don't don't need any super chat
that just leave it in the comments and
i'll
i'll read it yeah we don't care for your
well-being unless it's attached to money
superman the movie
superman the movie is not my fav one of
my favorite comic book movies but it's
really hard to top that perfect casting
of christopher reeves
it's that like that that's one of those
things with that with superman
specifically the movie the richard
donner one is uh
not one of my favorite comic book movies
but easily
one of the best casting choices yeah of
all time
yeah a thousand percent you know one for
as much as that movie gets right for
being like
one of the proto comic book superhero
movies you know i think there's there's
that you gotta appreciate for sure oh
absolutely
you know there's people mentioning this
in the chat right now the wolverine the
second one
you're the one in between logan and
origins
one that gets overshadowed by the
terrible and the great one
yeah dude the wolverine is a great film
i love that move i love that movie
that's one i'm most eager to revisit
actually due to your enthusiasm
like especially uh i mean have you only
seen it the one time
just in the theaters yeah dude you're
missing that first time which i've seen
i thought it was all right i liked it uh
let's see here my dad has to
ghost in the chat of death says dad has
the first spawn issue we're trying to
keep my trick
trying to keep on top of everything
today as much as possible oh the mask is
another one
mask is another combination god son of
the mask even better
the mask might have been the first comic
book movie i ever actually
watched or saw in the theaters at least
yeah
dream chaser i love your title how about
you should change your name to dream
achiever dream
rapper dream thief
just try and stop me from taking these
dreams oh john you should read this one
hi guys big fan since sean had
short hairs oh wow good thanks for
sticking it out
my favorite comic book movie has to be
end game because
it was the only movie that made me cry
ever damn that's a big moment which we
wait the only movie like only ever like
how many comic book movies how many
times did you cry
during which moments did you cry what
was the kicker that got the tears over
your eyelids
so wow i got so much to unpack with you
it's when thanos got his head cut off
i wanted i wanted just like
oh that's surprising well keep chasing
those dreams man
and don't be afraid to cry all the men
in this chat
never be afraid to cry cry once a day
always cry
cathartic um it's quality
uh we are not your source for this but
we'll answer your thank you thank you
for your super chat zachary's skulls
any news on the hersha aldi's blade yeah
still cast
gonna he's gonna be gay uh can't find
anything on it
even before corona hit what the [ __ ] is
going on with it you know
now that i think about it they are
keeping very i haven't heard
jack [ __ ] about that person and when you
sit back and go we've heard things about
phase five we've heard all kinds of
random ass rumors yeah they're
very quiet blade's gonna be introduced
to doctor strange multiverse madness
the only thing i've heard about blade in
recent memory was when mahershal
ali put up that instagram post of him
like a drawing of himself as the
character did he do that
yeah yeah and it just looks like him
with sunglasses i mean mahershali's
already played two comic book characters
can you name them
cottonmouth and uh or no he's not
actually caught in mouth
no he is the other he's not actually the
mandarin
alfred woodard is uh his diamondback no
um
cottonmouth and can you guys in the chat
name the two people mahersha ali has
already played in the comic book sphere
is this an obscure movie or i hope you
don't [ __ ] get this in your next
inner geekdom
or something [ __ ] gave this john
right now gave him an emotional memory
yeah
in the chat some people are mentioning
are we counting elita because that's
about oh that would be
three three i've saved myself on a
technicality what is that
i'm talking
oh my god you're really like having me
do this that's how geekdom works
see you in marshall it's just marvel
just marvel
okay um it's in the chat there are
people in the chat
i'm looking at chad's uh what what what
era of marvel
oh my god john it's prowler
oh he's the voice yeah
[Music]
fine have to move on he's not the donald
glover on screen
version of the game no no
no he's not no john come on that's where
i stumped you
yeah no that was good that was good that
was a good trick question
gotham show needs a movie i'm a i'm like
three episodes away from finishing the
gotham show dude
i agree and the only experience i have
with gotham is literally over my own
shoulder
when you're reacting and i'm always
looking over going what is happening it
looks cool
dude oh [ __ ] i totally forgot about a
little battle angel oh
[ __ ] but everyone in the chat was saying
proud
we were on the same page you know
once once it was all revealed i looked
and i saw um
let's see here niraj krishnan thank you
dude he is saying
doctor strange is also on my list for a
favorite comic book
movie that's a movie you really [ __ ]
love a lot i love
films or especially i see this a lot in
the anime shows that we react to
oh patreon i'll call this really is a
thing because i you know i was one of
those people who did get obsessed with
like things like the secrets
back in the day by the by rhonda byrne
and uh doctor strange really dealing a
lot with like
visualization and law of attraction
energy and stuff
i really appreciate that context uh yeah
uh dr strange is a pretty great one
that's
that's one you really love a lot you're
just a big scott derrickson fan in
general yeah i like scott derrickson
and i like um for me it's like it's
weird it's like i don't necessarily
think that it is like the
qualitatively best marvel movie or or
even like i don't know where i would put
it in a 10 in terms of that but yeah
just for like what it's
spelled out for the expansion of the
world and the sort of like
it gave me a rush and a dose of
something i'd been craving for so long
which was
yeah the spiritual aspects and the
surreal
you know really trippy visual qualities
and even the whole like therma thing
yeah
it's it's like there are parts of the
origin side that i can see being a
little familiar and a little less than
extraordinary for some people but i
think yeah just what that movie expands
the world into is so
freaking too you know who plays or
mamamoo
guys in the chat do you know who plays
dormammu
do you know who plays dormammu and
doctor strange
jeremy irons oh my god let's see who she
is
i'm waiting to see if anyone in the chat
happens to say it who played
i mean many other people i've had time
to wikipedia this [ __ ]
chihuahua i'm not going to quiz you
anymore john aldous hodge
uh matt damon is it matt damon
is it julia ah craig got it
oh benedict bendy dick cumberbatch don't
worry
john will still beat me in the inner
geekdom match oh thanks for stopping in
and saying hello and sending love anita
star
thank you anita uh she's moving to vegas
you know
i didn't know that although i i feel
like i could i mean
am i supposed to mention that i can see
that it's easy to find someone if you
just say vegas it's a very sensical
chapter and and i know anita is a bit of
a rolling stone so i can see that
working out yeah
um damn oh wait [ __ ] or did you move
already i need to hit you up to find out
yeah
let me text you all right uh dessert is
anita's birthday recently guys wish her
happy birthday happy birthday
uh aaron eric wallin
from uh that is not his name that is a
form of currency
thank you dude uh scott pilgrim versus
the world is one of my
favorites damn what is this [ __ ]
throne you're sitting dude it's like
carved out of a petrified tree or
something like this
wow you look [ __ ] epic that looks
like something jack sparrow would sit on
scott pilgrim versus the world i'm not a
big fan of the
i'm not a big fan of the world but
scott pilgrim just took me a long time
to like in that movie i've seen
i i i tried watching it once a long time
ago and then i re-watched it recently
i mean i finally watched it recently and
then when i got
i realized oh my issues scott pilgrim i
have a hard time liking
scott pilgrim the character i can see
that i mean i guess that's the whole
point he gets to sort of self-respect
and all that [ __ ]
but and he has to come of age and learn
to not be shitty about some things too
so yeah i can see why you wouldn't love
him uh let's see here let's see here
brittany lang
consistently changing consistently
changing the profile pics thank you
brittany lang
um oh something chad says scott pilgrim
sucks
oh wow are we fighting now are we gonna
fight that's the whole point you're not
supposed to like scott pilgrim that's
what everyone is michael b's saying
yeah i get it i get it alien versus
predator best comic book uh hey guys
how's it going with you guys
my favorite combo movie has to be iron
man and end game i feel like with all
the [ __ ] that mcu has spawned into
everyone forgets how the book ends
[ __ ] great iron man is
it you know yeah it's it's a solid
mental film
it's a solid movie solid [ __ ] thank
you for mentioning that thank you
brittany lang well and it still holds
that charm because when you go back and
revisit it it's it's like
more simple than the rest of the marvel
universe sort it's more contained and so
like it feels it maintains
like a specialness because of that i
think well yeah i mean uh
like the the few tie-ins are there but
at least shield is not just
there i i don't know you know in the
phase one
shield probably plays a better
implementation
in in the first thor movie uh but
shield does kind of help out with pepper
potts towards the finale
they're not just a setup you know
they're around they're they're doing
stuff
uh yeah let's see here is that michael
bay lobo movie still
like in the mill i feel like that i hope
he doesn't do it
i really hope he doesn't do it and
samal's games we have definitely
mentioned sin city but
i'm happy to keep talking about it
because uh it's one of
it may be my favorite comic book movie
wow good for you good for you
good for you
[Laughter]
um chris thank you dude wow what a great
thumbnail
john is watching this on patreon
agents of shield is the best comic book
tv show of all
atomic tv show it's the only one that
gets better every season and doesn't
slow down have you gotten a ghost rider
yet
no i'm only in season three and i think
ghost rider is
four or five right why are you not
satisfying the patrons and reacting
three times a day to ages of shields why
are you not doing it all the time why
have you not stopped put everything on
hold just to cover agency
on patreon i mean if we're talking in
that direction it is the one
show that would probably be easiest to
do that with but uh i'm not made of
eyeballs man
yeah all right i need to arrest them
sometimes and also
kind of keep the suspense up okay hey
hey i've seen it coming into this chat
saying the phantom was so terrible
the phantom the phantom with billy zane
starring billy
the [ __ ] william zane is so bad
it's also one of the most entertaining
movies i've ever seen and you know what
else is also
so bad but so entertaining but also
kind of [ __ ] cool the shadow
with alex baldwin oh my god i
never until a couple months ago like i
grew up listening to the shadow radio
dramas each weekend on am radio and when
i realized they made a movie
i was mind blown and i just watched it
wow and it was not what i was expecting
dude the shadows
soaked it's got a knife with a face that
bites his hand
it's so cool if you guys see the shadow
watch it it's
it's out there yeah never disrespect
billy zane he was in zoolander guys
one and and speaking of the shadow and
the phantom what about what about dick
tracy
oh dick tracy tracy do you know who got
nominated for that
uh the makeup
al pacino uh john i'm not gonna give you
the answer this time
you just have to learn on your own
uh yeah dick tracy is a pretty that came
out the year we were
born dick tracy yeah um that is a
pretty [ __ ] cool movie i i love al
pacino's character in that film
i love al pacino's character in that
finally someone's
mentioning uh dennis the wait a minute i
thought you were richie kingsman i don't
know how i misread that
50 50. dennis the menace the golden
circle
favorite comic book movie dennis the
mega yeah you
ytp ute what youtube people are crazy
is dennis the medicine comic book movie
i guess
i is it really i i think dennis the
menace is at least a comic strip
i don't i have never been aware of a
graphic novel
of dennis the menace yeah big storyline
that's involved it's
really intense very dark and it's a it's
about
uh you know uh human rights
but yeah that comic strip and the
illusion
how fascinating that is a pretty great
movie what's your math now man i'm gonna
say when are we gonna get
like a like a sabrina or a riverdale
shout out in here for the archie comics
fans
uh let's see here oh the spirit
i wanted that to be good seeing some
people talk about this frank miller's
the spirit you know what was funny about
that experience of watching the spirit
constantly giving john crap about how
heavy he breeds in movies
and then we snuck in to watch the spirit
we theater hopped
and then there was this guy sitting next
to him who was breathing very heavy
heavier than john and then john was like
i think i finally get where you're
coming from greg
yeah it was an eye opening it was an eye
opening and a mouth opening moment as
well
because you know that's a big great way
to quietly breathe through your freaking
mouth
lunapico lana who is a real person thank
you
lana lana hi guys hi
guys hi guys not a popular comic but my
dad used to watch the rocketeer all the
time
and i really loved it as a the rocketeer
is it's like a class it's like
experiencing the weirdest resurgence
yeah man it's like 90 it's fine it's
like right at 1990 i but 90 1990 or 91
was somewhere there it's right there and
in terms of 90s nostalgia
the rocketeer is skyrocketing back
into nostalgia world it's pretty crazy
how
how much love that movie is getting
thank you lon i really appreciate that
it's a good profile pixel i'm gonna say
one of these days i'm gonna have to go
check out the rockets
keep it low-key i feel like anything
more it's dropping near our
collective births helped me to kind of
not
uh be exposed to tim wing in the chat
has mentioned the movie push
starring chris evans produced by guess
who
chris evans malcolm l gibson believe it
or not
yeah there are two random ass actor
producer real roles i'm aware of that's
one and now leonardo dicaprio producing
the film
orphan ellen look at that uh let's see
here
anisa thank you so much my dear how you
doing love thank you anisa
how about this do y'all have any
recommendations for combo movies that's
what i want to know thank you greg for
always be there of course i'm always
there for your knees so we talked
we talked throughout the week yeah i'd
recommend catwoman
i'd recommend elektra uh
because you know i'm woke ultraviolet
man ultraviolet man
no i mean the ones that some of them are
the ones i mentioned earlier like a
little bit more of the low-key ones that
some people don't really think of like
sin city history of violence road to
prediction
wanted is another one that i think does
not get enough love um and i think that
[ __ ] deserves a sequel i don't know
why it hasn't happened yet
you see at the time with wanted i i get
why
the sequel didn't come was because of
what the
i don't wanna i mean i'm going to uh oh
angelina jolie
what happened to the character in the
movie and james mcavoy honestly
wasn't [ __ ] james he wasn't yet you
know but now james mcavoy is
james mcavoy so i think i wanted to
would
work right now yeah just bring him back
that many years later for some kind of
weird curving the bullet type scenario
why the [ __ ] i feel like you can make
something even cooler that wanted
uh kick ass uh yeah more of those and
some of the alan moore stuff like v
for vendetta has from hell
you know as much as i've heard that that
is not a well-done adaptation of the
source material and
from thumbing through the source
material is dense but i
i i like things about that movie
i do enjoy it yeah but thank you thank
you anissa i really appreciate that
uh let's see here where are we at who's
who's next on the list here ooh fun me
productions thank you funny non-tights
guys are new i would hit the like button
thank you fun me um
fun me we reacted to one of his videos
forever ago yeah uh
non-tights snow piercer uh controversial
choice ultimate edition of bvs which
is definitely superior over the
theatrical version
objectively marvel's spider-man 2
dc dark knight anime
dc dark knight anime oh the dark knight
returns is another great one going off
anissa's another question today and
fleming reminded me the dark knight
returns is a great animated
uh dc film and i i feel like a lot part
one and part two are both great
i think a lot of people didn't um
have support for it in the beginning
because the fact that they cut out all
the
great frank miller written in internal
monologue stuff
but actually in terms of uh film medium
it's pretty awesome so if you haven't
seen the dark knight returns i made a
film
i highly recommend checking that out uh
live action
bleach oh god i didn't know that they
did a live action bleep dark horse
hellboy two boats get an army boy this
is a lot of great movies that we have
already listed already so thank you dude
for that gotta watch snow piercer
i know it's gotta be the next on the
list
so that we can jump onto the show that i
have heard is equally good
um and then he also mentions the
incredible whole 2008 great score
underrated oh i need to remember who
scored that movie i know who directed it
uh when in doubt with this movie to say
edward norton
probably wanted to score it and then
they forced him to use a composer
i will say man also yeah another comic
book movie i gotta recommend going back
to anissa cause they're all coming back
the crow if you haven't seen the crow
watch the crow
um uh incredible hulk that f that final
fight scene in harlem between
abomination and hulk
is still one of my favorite fights in
all of the mcu yeah that's right
not a big fan of the movie overall but
but the finale
uh that final fight is still pretty
goddamn great
i don't want to bring down the mood but
i did see tommy rogers wrote
r.i.p george floyd so yeah i want to
acknowledge
for sure of course bring it up man world
is uh yeah i mean we brought it up at
the beginning of the livestream and
yeah like uh highly encourage you guys
i mean i think for george floyd's
funeral donations i think he's a little
over seven million
right now um which is [ __ ] amazing
and wonderful uh
i'm not not the fact that it's of what
over that he's having a funeral with the
fact that that's on supporters but
in terms of black lives matter you can
go blacklivesmatter.com
it is donate section right there uh if
you just want to donate to that
uh campaign and uh that movement yeah
yeah
there's also donated right before we
hopped on the stream so make sure to go
over there i forget the name but there's
also you can donate directly to the
folks in minneapolis who are out there
too
for you know food and uh you know things
like that crazy fees my girlfriend was
just at a protest
and she and she is she was right there
cop guard got set on fire
and uh uh people i mean
order for revolution [ __ ] like this
needs to happen though okay so
i'm in support of people protesting
there's a lot i am there's a lot yeah
there i feel like there's a lot of
things you can talk about but i'm always
reminded of that i think it's an mlk
quote of a riot is the language of the
unheard and
so even though i think you can debate
the merits of looting or whatever just
the unrest and the physical action taken
in the face of
lack of change you know i i yeah i can't
take that away from anybody
all right we'll do we'll do little
mentions here there yeah yeah
little little mentions all about it all
right
segway though uh this is the first time
i've seen big hero 6 mentioned which is
technically a marvel disney animation
movie
animation and big hero 6 the the action
sequences are like a
great anime yeah you know
yeah san francisco incredible
um the kaltur turrux
fifth member of the black order here
half almost hated wonder woman in the no
man's scene because of all the sjw crap
all the time if wonder woman went
lord of the rings with i am no man would
have
lost it well i mean i don't know what to
tell you dude i mean i appreciate your
super chat but it's
it's called wonder woman you know it's
gonna yeah
just because it's about a woman doesn't
make it
sjw i'd say you know i get the
i i i guess if that part of this
culture irritates you i guess i can see
how the lead up to wonder woman would
make you
wary of that tone of voice however i
think wonder woman is one of the ones
that
manages to handle its progressive ideals
uh
uh within the realm of the movie and not
just like it's spraying them at you from
the periphery
i can i can feel it whenever it's like a
dude probably wrote this
it is trying yeah or when it's one of
those like ah for marketing let's let's
throw in a gay character in the
background but i think
uh i think wonder woman in my opinion i
thought handled it very well very
natural and it's
wonder woman so yeah you're expecting
some
themes like that to come up that's
another thing with it you know
yeah there will be a point where we
don't acknowledge it anymore like one
thing i want to see
happen um that i'm waiting for is to
there to be an action hero and him to
not
and for a male action hero and it's like
let him be gay but
don't like don't call much attention
don't call attention to it no need for
the derogatory f word about gay people
to be thrown in there or giggles
like just the thing about him is i feel
like that's
usual like one of my favorite versions
of representation in film
is the movie sideways um
uh oh my god forget her name the girl
from grey's anatomy um
sandra oh she's an asian character one
of the prominent female characters in
that movie
and you never they never acknowledge
that she's asian you know
and at the time when that came out they
usually will will do something and i
don't think there's a problem with
necessarily acknowledging it but to me i
love that kind of representation in
films where it's like yeah you're a
casting asian girl but never call
attention to the fact that she's asian
but she's still one of the main
characters
uh that's usually my favorite version of
that kind of representation in movies
well yeah anytime you include
diversity is best included when it's not
like screamingly
you know highlighted because i i i often
think to the theory of like when you do
charitable acts or good things you're
not supposed to call attention to
yourself and i feel like that's
kind of how you're supposed to approach
social justice in
fiction is put it in and treat those
characters like humans
and that's all you gotta do i think
that's something not to say that george
rr martin is the bastion of feminist
writers or whatever but i feel like
there was a piece of advice that blew
people's minds he gave out once which is
like how do you write such
great female characters and he's like i
don't know i just kind of approached
them like
people yeah and the character just kind
of comes along with that
um let's see here let's see here eric
horseman thank you dude
i actually really enjoyed shazam and
aquaman not too hip on columns but i
think it may be a dcu fan more than mcu
also not a movie but the boys if you
haven't seen the boys on amazon
do it as soon as you can it is so good
also the preacher show is pretty damn
good too but the boys is my preferred
uh television show to watch preachers
one i've been meaning to jump back on
because i was really
really enamored with those first couple
episodes and the
graphic novel i read was nuts um i would
say
uh i i would really say that uh
there's things about the dc you the ec
universe that i think that they're doing
that
are and there are things they're doing
that i wish
marvel and mcu would would do some of
in terms of like i think a dce has been
killing it lately
um aquaman's not one of my favorite ones
of theirs but it was a big hit
uh shazam was great wonder woman we're
one of the
two people who like birds of prey like
we like birds of prey
and that might be towards the top of my
dcu list
and um you know joker obviously like
taking the chance the
the chances are taking especially with
the r rating material
there's things there that i i think and
they're not so
like dependent on the the tie-ins
anymore granted they had to make a lot
of
mistakes along the way they had to i
don't know about mistakes they had to
receive a lot of
criticism along the way before they
really were able to bring it in the
direction it's in now
but even with the snyder cut being
included in there i'm like that's
[ __ ] cool
yeah that's really definitely got a
uniquely constructed universe going
yeah thanks queens uh xu shizu for being
in the chat you're saying
so many nice things right now and thanks
for saying real house it look like a
young martin scorsese
thanks oh wow that's a nice little
compliment there i know
everyone wants to look like martin
scorsese that's the italian man you want
to look like
especially when talking about comic con
that are cinema caltor adding on thank
you buddy um monroe did not go there and
loved it for it
wonder woman was not better because she
was woman she was just badass exactly
yeah i wish we got to your second part
of your comments right away
i just threw it on top we were right on
the same path there so thank you dude
appreciate that
oh yeah and there are other lessons i
think for for her to learn which make
that that movie well-fleshed you know
what almost
she loves them dick that's right
wonderful woman
she sees it and there's a lot damn i
want that
give me one where can i get one i'm
surprised nobody
has dropped uh the adventures of tintin
in here
because that's that's the comic book uh
comics
if you know comics strip at the very
least and i think it became
books and graphic novels and stuff no
but uh i'm
i'm not sure john but uh yeah i was just
shout it out anyway
oh damn i thought we were on top of
everything with the super chats and we
have fallen behind oh
no john talks too long john
that's what i gotta do is blame john
blame and things fall
let's see here all right john how do we
do this all right guys we're talking
about great joe johnston movies i
thought we were on top of it but
we've fallen behind let's do this let's
do this
let's catch up babar the elephant is a
boss who's next scuba
scuba esteban dude thank you scuba steve
films all the homeboy on instagram right
here
lovely little stacker uh michael b
is saying uh serious seriously no man of
steel end game aquaman scott pilgrim
tmnt 90s
one and two and the crow blade
spider-verse the dark knight
spider-man mate those are all fantastic
films thank you
batman begins dude batman begins
is my favorite batman film the dark
knight's my favorite
film out of the dark knight trilogy but
batman begins my favorite
batman film but thank you dude and also
tmnt
teenage mutant ninja turtles man part
two
secret of the use pretty [ __ ] cool
vanilla ice appears in there
go in his career did that ruin his
career
i mean that was a big part of like his
career yeah
how the mighty eminem does a venom song
and then
it just bolts clearly vanilla ice should
have waited a couple decades before
doing go ninja
yeah that's all we needed was a few
other records under his belt
the sword with the leonardo the stick
with the donatello michelangelo with the
numchucks and the
dump [ __ ] who drive pickup trucks
that's my eminem donatello fellows with
this stick
wearing a girl as i fight the ninja
turtles
[Music]
back at it again also off topic here i'd
like to hear y'all's opinions of what
has happened in minneapolis i find it to
be truly heartbreaking
well i mean we don't want to make this
one too political
uh but at the same time you're asking us
a question thank you for the super chat
by the way
uh what what's going on in minneapolis
is
absolutely like you know what the thing
is i'm just gonna say
i think it's necessary i think what's
happening right now is necessary some
might argue
that we're just creating more damage or
whatever but i think right now
voices need to be hurt and it's
absolutely [ __ ] important
so what's happened in minneapolis while
there's been some terrible [ __ ]
things that have been going on
um as well within these these riots and
stuff
them protesting is an absolute essential
thing right now
yeah i mean i mean around the world i
mean more than minneapolis you know
i mean yeah because this is one of those
problems that has established itself as
a cycle
and you know there are only so many
times we can all sit around going i'm
shocked before you yeah just get
fed up and uh yeah i mean i haven't seen
everything
that's going on out there and again i
know that there are arguments to be made
about the concept of looting and
vandalism and actually i was watching
last night a couple speeches one of
which was uh from killer mike
and uh you know there have been a lot of
people speaking out on this and yeah i
think it's
regardless of of the methodology it's
absolutely
necessary because you know if if the
whole
foundation of the country that you live
in isn't here to help you out and
protect you
as some [ __ ] and uh you know things
need to be done about it and it's clear
that the normal channels haven't worked
as of yet so again i'm just reminded of
that
idea that the riot is the voice of the
unheard
so yeah i'm i can't blame anybody for
feeling the way that they feel and i
just hope that
we can better intervene on this very
human situation
of yeah like just watching the footage
with that officer with his knee on on on
yeah george floyd's throat i just yeah
and uh
most vile image i've seen in a long time
you know what guys
uh [ __ ] donald trump that's what i'm
gonna say too all right
you know what i mean as much as you can
go [ __ ] himself
looting starts shooting starts uh yeah
you can go [ __ ] yourself
as much as i'm not about to say as much
as i'm not about to say that twitter
is is the beacon of justice in this
world i didn't think it was pretty funny
that even twitter was like
this tweet has been blocked for you know
violent incisive language
uh property damage he started they start
speaking up but when uh george floyd
and the police get away with it no it
doesn't say [ __ ]
well that's [ __ ] that guy and that's
the huge problem and that's that's a big
thing about
rioting and looting again is is those
objects and that
[ __ ] that people are gonna buy is all
insured it's covered by banks and it's
not more important than human lives and
so yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] trump [ __ ] them every which
way
anyway back to the comic book movies
back to the fun
this is going to be the way the stream
goes the thing is i i have a feeling it
would be brought up that's why i brought
her up at the
very beginning of the stream because i i
know at some point that
people will be asking about it because
it's the thing that's happening right
now
well everyone's a little bit like that's
why i do normal [ __ ] right now but
that's also why i'm encouraging you guys
go to blacklivesmatter.com and you can
donate right there
i literally did it two minutes before
the stream um
it was it took me like 30 seconds to log
it
to go to the website and then go to the
donate section so go to
blacklivesmatter.com
heavily encourage it just yeah quickly
especially sean
this is what i'm talking about well no i
i again i heard a great quote yesterday
that you're if you're sitting there
thinking you know like i have
you know uh friends of color various
that you know it's if you think it's not
your issue just because you're a white
person think of all the people in your
life and if any of those people
are affected by this then it's your
problem too yes yeah exactly yeah
if we all care about each other from
yeah like this is [ __ ]
like like people can get mad at what
culture all they want but really
you know like does not was beyond that
[ __ ] all right it's about equality
it's about [ __ ] equality well yeah
and if i mean if police were rampantly
killing white people i'm sure a lot more
property would be destroyed by now
anyway back to combat movies mainly star
white people
do it white cinema
what's your favorite white people movie
oh white chicks um
all right all right let's get back to
you
this is the one i've been poking right
here from audigied screecher thank you
so much dude kingsman
the secret service is so special to me
the movie that gave us karen edgerton
thank you for bringing that up
king's been i mean i've seen people talk
about in the chat um
i we really like the golden circle too
i really like the golden circle i'm
weirdly not i'm not excited for the
third one
it looks all right um oh that's right
no one's talked about how that one's
been delayed um
oh yeah you forgot um oh dude no judas
thundersteel i see your comment don't
you worry but i'm gonna mention that
soon
um uh [ __ ] uh kingsman the secret
service in kingsman the golden circle i
think are wonderful films
secret service is a better movie i i
i generally speaking i think but uh
like to me that is the defining matthew
vaughn style i know it's not hit one of
wait no it is an r-rated movie that is
one of you like that
there are a couple gags in both kingsman
films that actually kind of bother me
that make those very rages
i mean i feel like they're like uh x-men
first classes or people might go to a
kick-ass
but no kingsman right there that's my
that's probably my favorite matthew
vaughn movie the
the very first one because it has the
perfect blend
of like edgy heart style
everything right there so thank you for
mentioning uh that attitude
screecher what a fascinating name you
got there and thanks
mark strong in that movie merlin so
incredible
and bloodshot is also a great movie what
the fact that you could maybe accredit
some of the existence of rocket man in
its forum
two kings in the golden circle perhaps
something i appreciate as well
perhaps all right moving on here uh
patrick sharma thank you dude
except for batman begins he has appeared
in all batman films from batman forever
to bvs donald justin the ammo series
he's actually a u.s senator
named this politician uh
batman film god oh i don't i can't name
him but i know this story
he is actually a u.s senator yeah
there's a u.s senator who is appearing
he's a batman fan like like a
real us center yeah not like some easter
egg character but a real us senator
who's appeared in all these batman films
this sounds familiar to me unless i'm
just mandela affecting myself who is
cartier talking about
do you guys know can you name it in the
chat yeah the thing is i know i've heard
this person's name and
i just i'm not gonna get it until i hear
it back who is
this person that's talking about that's
a i really wanna i really wanna know who
this u.s senator is
is it uh i'm waiting for the chat to
answer who's the famous senator
patrick lee uh t townsend says in the
chat
leahey i have no idea i'm going to look
out look him up
look his face up thank you karthik for
mentioning that that's cool
all right is he a good senator terrible
terrible senator i'm like this is the
first time where i've directly gone to
is it how's this guy's politics am i
gonna be psyched about this or not
um let's see here peter pacheco is
saying
thank you peter pacheco love your
captain spalding thumbnail here
dc dark knight marvel infinity war
honorable mention the original blade
no one talks about blade t i love blade
too man it was ron perlman donnie yen in
the same movie
yeah i don't hear it bro obviously not
yet in the stream but
i thought blade 2 is one of those
sequels that people actually like uh
maybe more than the first i loved the
first like
15 minutes of blade one the part where
your dad made you walk out of it on
i because that came out in 98 or he's
eight years old watching right yeah
i was like this is a bad [ __ ]
um yeah i i think uh i i like
blade one a lot uh i mean i like blade
two the most out of them all
uh blade one the opening 15 minutes that
whole club
sequence is wonderful um
honestly that final fight with him and
steven dorff i i don't
care for and that's supposed to be like
the best or biggest fight of it all and
they're just doing the same spinning
heel kick
constantly i thought it was a really
poorly choreographed fight
that's where my quirky system for blade
comes in but now i get why people
the style and wesley science personality
that it brings so he really helped a lot
with infusing and making changes to that
character uh
so yeah i would say yeah i get that i
get that thanks for being here
you my favorite watchman character is
rorschach like most people
then when you learn about what
watchman's about you're like oh what
does that say about me
zachary scholes thank you buddy uh
brandon lee the crow r.i.p
brandon lee terrible thing of how that
guy died on that
do you know do you guys know this would
never get brought up in inner gate
themselves shares
do you know who who doubled for
brandon lee on the crow and
uh he only had three days left to shoot
before he died while filming that film
and so the stunt double filled in for
brandon lee
uh for the additional photography that
they needed to complete
the motion picture do you know who that
stunt double was
come on guys one of you has to know
that's the same i would be able to pull
i'll give you a hint he's a film
director okay
it's not chat that should not chance it
is chat
yeah damn really it's chad stahlski
wow what a yeah what a mantle to have
jesus
took an additional eight million dollars
to finish that movie and uh
yeah chad sahelsky was the chazzalski
you guys i know it was the director of
the john wick films
he was the sun double for the if you
guys haven't seen the crowd you should
really watch the crowd yeah the crows
is a magic special piece of little
cinema there i mean we have seen the new
hellboy movie i know the guy did the
makeup for it so i thought i should
watch it big fans of
it and speaking of the crow and this is
back in the chat
guys if you're new here hit the like
button please uh if you haven't done so
already please do
the crow is my second favorite movie
such a good movie i know we've talked
about this
of course the matrix is my number one
and yeah we've talked about that
shazam is also a great comic book movie
zachary levi is amazing they better hop
on that sequel
because asher angel's gonna he's growing
up it's probably cast
not just ash or angel um uh freddy
freeman uh jack dylan grayson
he's grown up too you know they're gonna
have to they're gonna have to like
it chapter two this and like re shape
their heads and stuff
they gotta get on that man uh the crow
is definitely one of my top 10 favorite
man uh do you know who plays the cop in
the crow
do you know who plays a detective in the
crow i'm not telling you judge philip
banks oh my god
but the matrix i wish the the matrix is
heavily inspired by
uh anime and comic books properties so
in some ways that counts
wait a minute fight club was a book was
it was it a comic
ever quiet the sequel to fight club
was a graphic novel i don't think the
original fight club source material was
i don't think that is a graphic novel
but
i know the sequel for sure totally is so
then my follow-up question is can we
count
jesus movies because there is a comic
book bible
yes yes then the passion of christ is my
favorite comic book
inspired based things yes and random
annie's channel thank you i support
protests i don't support
riot and violence well i can respect
that now sometimes it leads to that i
think the properties will be fine
you know it depends yeah it's weird i've
heard some really great arguments for
not destroying stuff and i've heard some
understandable arguments for destroying
stuff
the good news is people are finally
being heard yes
and i hope i hope it's a long lasting
effect all right that's that's the
problem with it because
well it needs to be the start of a whole
chain there's like the rodney king
uh incident and then there was riots
there and everything and now we're back
to this one and it's like when's it
gonna
you know what's happening how changed
years
even before rodney king you know when
are we gonna decades and decades and
decades
alleviate some of yeah these toxic
pieces of our makeup
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah anyway
even though that's how we'll transition
everything today transition
ethan holgate thank you dude uh megamind
planet 51 both great animated movies
haven't seen megaman have you seen
megamind with will ferrell
uh yeah wilfred brad pitt right
i'm not sure i don't remember brad pitt
being in that movie i think christian
wig is in or something
i'm glad to see some mega mine love you
know i i watched a little bit of on on
tv and it was pleasant
in that uh setting so yeah i will say
that i rushed out to a theater to see it
but
uh oh 50 50 is he has a great comment
about representation
lana lang and smallville is one of the
best brown representations of all time
that's true kristen crook as uh lana
lang i wish you worked more she played
chun li the
other live-action street street fighter
the legend
of the great chris klein performance i
don't think they ever
mentioned that she is asian as lana lang
and um in uh in uh smallville it's
fallville yeah i don't think i ever did
that
that's cool yeah nice i'm glad to hear
that oh that's crazy to hear
do you know who played lana lane
superman three
oh damn it i've seen superman three
but all i can think of is richard price
i'll give you a hint
she's in smallville okay
good luck john rosen michael rosenbob
tom welling
kristen krueg i have now exhausted all
of my knowledge of the smallville cast
a lot of pico back in the chat real
person hi lana
he wanted also a great comic film for me
angelina jolie was dope it was my first
introduction to james mcavoy
sorry i've already mentioned don't be
sorry this is the first time usually
we're like an hour behind with the super
chats and now we're only 20 minutes
behind
so but i did mention this in 20 minute
time three times better
we they should make a wanted sequel they
really should
i think james mcavoy deserves to go out
on a high note for a
[ __ ] change honestly yeah like his
last career
no i mean i think his last this last
[ __ ] charles xavier film
was the dark phoenix um uh
kevin uh kevin and it wasn't kevin crum
kevin crum and glass
and it's like come on man wanted give
him a wanted sequel
give him a good one it's equal and
freaking in chapter two like it's
good but he didn't get used very great
that's what i mean yeah he deserves it
he deserves yeah like a major he's at
the center of it and it's
hit well oh and i wanna thank you lana
thank you it's a wonderful profile pic
everyone has wonderful profile pics
today y'all are beautiful all of y'all
and no wasn't kristen crook who was
involved in this
in the sex trafficking scandal all right
it was the other blonde girl
oh white woman yeah all the white woman
in the world are involved
um conan the barbarian is that is that a
yeah that is a comic book right holy
[ __ ] yeah forget that
i'm sitting here going was it a comic
book first or or did it later get
because you know there are movies like
that like kick ass like the comic was
being written as
the movie was being written you know
things like that
uh michael williams what's up dude
that's a that's
that's impressive that's like a really
confident looking
intriguing you got like i don't know
yeah you got this attitude i like
watching min movie was very amazing very
underrated
oh do you i mean i haven't seen the
director's cup but i hear the director's
cut is
exceptionally better than they every
zack snyder extended version of anything
that he
does is the better version snyder has
this thing where i guess he can only
make a complete film if it's
four hours long but uh i would love you
know
in fact that is the zack snyder
director's cut i would be
most compelled to sit down and really
take in really
yeah just because like watchmen i think
you know if you look at sucker puncher
you look at bvs like i'm sure bvs will
be more intelligible
but like i liked what watchmen was going
for i like the tone
that it was going for and i think that
it does enough things pretty beautifully
that i would watch
you know a more fleshed version to like
that's always a movie where i've
i've heard people say and i kind of
share that opinion of like i think
there's a lot to uh appreciate here but
i'm not entirely sure if zack snyder
either understands or is going for what
the comic is actually about
basically um guys i want to say there's
some people here who are in minneapolis
who who like live in minneapolis we're
in this chat oh [ __ ]
please be safe be safe be safe as
possible while i do think that
the the protests are necessary please be
safe
it's very safe i mean it's not very safe
please be very safe
so safe we fell behind again here all
right
random annie's channel is back here
saying being plus
love wonder soldiers uh winter soldiers
sorry for being negative nah dude you're
just expressing your opinion man no
worries dude
um winter soldier is yeah that seems to
it's funny how after all these films
winter soldier still seems to be one of
the movies
that people it seems like it's hard for
that one to be beat
that's the beacon of phase two i mean i
kind of want the russo brothers to go
back to
if they rejoin the mcu i want them to do
something a little bit on
like winter soldiers small for mcu scale
um contained is what we mean when we say
small
i mean yeah especially compared to
contains the civil war
and infinity war end game that's small
for the russo brothers
but i really think that uh it would be
cool if they returned if they went back
to something on a more contained scale
like winter soldier kind of going back
to not their roots because their roots
would be a
you mean dupreeh there's something a lot
more along those lines you know i would
want to yeah i would want to
see something where it makes me go okay
like what what are they going to bring
to this with sensibility not just like
are they going to manage juggling all
this [ __ ]
yeah like i would much i i really mad
respect for infinity war and end game
but i would be most excited for them to
come back and and do something more
contained where i'm yeah okay let's get
the russo brother's
voice back in here whatever yeah oh
nissa you're so sweet she's saying i
love you all so much thank you anissa
that's really exciting
um we love you you know i love you
i care about you things have been a
little rough lately anissa but much
care about you eric horseman sometimes
you gotta burn it down and build it up
again fever233
hashtag black lives matter abso [ __ ]
lutely
yes i completely agree with you eric
horseman i actually saw a great tweet
going around
about like you know black people can
burn down
uh the properties because like they help
build it for free
yeah like like they're gonna wanna argue
with that person you know like it's very
true
yeah built on the backs of a lot of
unjust free labor
you gotta change the foundation of this
system dude we really do so i agree with
you thank you for that comment eric
horseman
i do agree with you go to
blacklivesmatter.com donate today
um chase gardner back here in the chat
thank you chase
hey what's up chase uh let's see here oh
wait no
i think i got him right here hold on oh
yeah hans zimmer batman trilogy
favorite soundtrack these are iconic
well
those affected all of soundtracks for a
while i think what a lot of people don't
realize is han zimmer was co-composer
for two out of the three films and it's
only the dark knight rises
where he composed that solely
without james newton howard yeah and
james howard doesn't get enough credit
i think for his contribution to batman
begins and the dark knight because those
are two composers with different styles
yeah like yeah that's a [ __ ] concern
what have you done for us that's a great
call that's a very
i he does like and now
with hans i think on zimmer did make a
declaration that he doesn't want to do
any more comic book movies
it was after like bvs or something right
i wouldn't be surprised i mean like his
style has become like so ubiquitous for
that genre especially
you know it's not bbs it was man of
steel it was made of steel yeah no
junkie xl did bvs yes yes yes yes
oh junky excel's done some pretty uh
sweet score like
a snyder cut like this
speaking of also uh the one reason i'm
most compelled to check out capone
actually is because
lp who's half of run the jewels and who
does a lot of the musical side of run
the jewels did the music so
really i'm like oh damn i wanna check
that soundtrack out
uh abraham lincoln vampire hunter yeah
it's kind of snooze
some people are saying that in the chat
it's a in a saturday morning or
a friday midnight kind of way i like
that movie but yeah it's not
it's not amazing um
what scorsese did a bible-era comic
strip when he was a kid i didn't know
that oh i want to
i want to look that up peter pacheco
back with the captain spalding 2007.
also gold swirl sci-fi i've
never seen a birch never heard a sigh
i've never seen
sci-fi's deadly class i've heard of it
ghost world 2000
no you must be the first person ever in
my life to bring up where my american
splinter yeah yes i'm i'm happy
in this chat one of my favorite things
is that the 2007 tmnt is getting some
love
it's always whatever we got on here it
[ __ ] deserves it
um go out and buy a copy of tmnt uh
let's see here
han sim oh oh i think khan zimmer and
junkie excel both worked on bvs thank
you
sean for clearing that up i can see that
i can see that
no you can hear that ah well what if i'm
reading the liner notes of the
soundtrack album
gregory i'm sorry you hey hey
you dumbass you would have failed us in
the showdown
thank you lana oh how did i how did i
ever get
invited into this league wait a minute
uh what's today thank you
what's the name of the frozen marvel
universe crossover movie
cheers to you my sister got me this cup
it's this
thor ragnarok cup greg let me borrow
this cup i don't know where he goes yeah
i was like we need comic book cups today
yeah cause they're
in theme uh let's see here oh that's a
screwdriver
so uh so did brad pitt play will ferrell
as megaman
no brad pitt also underrated voice work
he does a great episode of king of the
hill where he plays boomhauer's brother
anisa okay what's capped i haven't
actually read your joke
uh the pun i think damn i don't know do
you have your punchline here
i'm seeing all these things in the chat
about her what's captain marvel's
favorite cheese
oh is there a pun in here
is it like is burria cheese yes
is it brie b-r-i-e bree it smell like
brie larson's name
yeah is it bree it's gotta be brie
otherwise it's something blue
because of you know uh cree blood it is
that's good that's a great call yeah
because i i should have put
that's good three is delicious cheese
all right that is
good i had brie cheese for the first
time last week uh
uh alyssa ferrari uh no alyssa cybert
now
did she take his last name or did dan
take a listen ferrari yeah
i mean i would [ __ ] go with ferrari
over cyprus
maybe they'll do a hyphen where dan's
name is first
cybert ferrari dan
for rybert uh down way off about hans
emery [ __ ] did goddamn x-men during
phoenix
well maybe he recanted when they offered
him money
i mean that's usually all it takes right
just just
i feel like i really educated a lot of
people that chad stahlski was the stunt
double for
brandon lee you educated me that's what
i'm talking about john
come to me for the information guys i'm
your information
guy the snack snyder is the best
director to dvd director i'll give you
that
uh at least the uh intended cuts i think
uh
cyberpunk will be multiplayer guns uh
characters
anissa why is the punisher the best
marvel character oh let me see if i can
get this
punished frank castle this is not a
joke because yeah it has to be a joke
right or
like it has to be a joke it's like i
didn't peg him as your favorite marvel
character
um okay damn
i don't know do you have it later on
here in the chat marvel character
um because he
uh thomas james because he's frank
about everything he's very frank he's
very frank with everyone
frank with his rage because he helped
build the marvel castle
i'm gonna keep looking at the comments
and see if you have it here because he's
even
less micro than a regular chat [ __ ] i
gotta find your [ __ ] answer
god damn i can't find it oh no it's in a
super chat god
damn it it'll come up after these two
all right i need someone looked it up
eric horseman thank you dude
and he's talking about anissa and you
see you're cracking me up much you
laughing this way when's your stand-up
special dropping annie
we need the jokes um oh
what do you call what i'm gonna okay i
got one i got one i
i told john forever i go no is it my
favorite one about
a director yeah yeah what do you call
james gunn when he works on his glutes
james buns oh yeah
well i love that joke what would you
call every once in a while i'll just
come up with these randomly while we're
editing i'll just tell john i'll just
like
look over here hey what do you call
ellen degeneres when she's committing a
crime
you're gonna kick yourself if you don't
get it oh god um
what is a person who does crimes
especially convicted
criminal synonym synonym for criminal
you give up yeah felon degeneres
[Laughter]
yeah what are your y'all what do you
call george clooney
if he was cast as ant-man george
p union there you go
yeah i'm gonna create a book of these
so jin joy and the chatter scene i guess
the punisher is the best marvel
character because he doesn't make puns
i'm sorry puns zachary skulls
uh corona the barbarian jesus christ
on top of all these crimes and the
protests are happening around
we've still got a pandemic going on
isn't that crazy whose body count is
larger conan's or
coronand's uh coronanz uh
corona the barbell zachary stay in the
chat that's great
loving these jokes i think uh thank you
zachary
well dude uh it's pretty nuts be like
right now
the stay-at-home orders are supposed to
lift in california
next week but we have seen a [ __ ]
rise in case like that there's a day
where they let uh they they're like all
right i'll retail
and some restaurants can be open i was
like we got like a gazillion more cases
today
like not enough tests yeah i don't
i don't know what's happening i think
trump is great
oh [ __ ] wait [ __ ] hold on a second all
right i got it
so why is the punisher the greatest uh
marvel character
because it has the best punch lines
why is he the funniest marvel kid oh my
god i think that might give it away too
hard
god what are the other ones i had oh man
oh jeepers what were the other ones
james buns is just so prolific
all right all right uh i mean
uh no that wouldn't be appropriate for
today i was guessing is my liam neeson
phillip defranco one
there's other ones out there uh they'll
come we'll just create some new ones
[Music]
uh let's see here oh yeah deadpool man
no one's [ __ ] talking about deadpool
and have luke skywalker in the chat
thanks luke skywalker marcus is talking
about it all right
uh how do you get anissa oh i think this
is gonna be good
how do you get batman into the marvel
universe
say that name why did you say that name
yeah just say martha it'll just come
through a wall like the kool-aid man
i don't know with a with a grappling
hook he's gonna climb
in uh oh you're close you're close
hang him on the wall now he's a bruce
banner
oh anita are you coming up with these on
your own
dude i'm serious publish your own like
whimsical cartoon comic book jokes book
oh damn denise is getting a lot of love
in the chat you're stealing the chat
what do you call the riddler when he is
pleasuring himself
um i don't know what the diddler
[Laughter]
i forgot that they're dj diddles
that's what my mind went straight to
damn oh i forgot that one
back in the dia barbed wire oh you know
what
that is a comic what he also composed
this i was way wrong
he said around man of steel or bvs time
he said he's not gonna do them anymore
now he's been doing them
whatever well warner brothers came to
him and they're like
hans you're the one thing people agree
on about our current lineup
you gotta stick with us it's funny i
just drove past the warner
brothers studio they still have their
june 5th wonder woman 1984 posters up
really that are yeah like the huge ones
on the boulevard
as well as a supernatural final season
poster which always warms my heart
even though we're only on season five on
patreon come check us out
kaltur turux thank you kaltur
winter soldier bummed me out heard
better than avengers i thought avengers
x2 two different movies i went thinking
wrong
like it now that's the problem with
expectations
versus expectations anticipation when
you go to watch the actual movies you
know expectations
that can't interfere at the same time it
can make movies
like how i watch green lantern for the
first time this week not be
as bad because i heard nothing but
terrible things about it
so when i went to go watch it i was
expecting something significantly worse
and instead i walked out going there
were ways this movie could have been
good
you know what i mean god have you ever
seen a movie with a people like i feel
like usually when people prepare you for
something to be bad it's never that bad
but every once in a while it is or worse
have you seen a movie like that where
like people are like oh you're gonna
hate this and you're like
no i like this even less than you led me
to
uh there's one movie that's ever done
that to me that i can at least draw
directly to memory but
what is it the remake of nightmare and
elves
oh man no i did not know that people
were like john this movie sucks you're
not gonna
like it and when i watched it i was like
oh yeah it probably won't be that bad
though and and when i watched i was like
even the things i like platinum dunes
movies for
just devoid in this project and it made
me
upset han zimmer's working on the new uh
[ __ ] wonder woman movie what and you
know what i take it back
hans zimmer's only going to score god
i've changed my mind i'm doubling down
double triple down ah let's see here all
right
okay okay there's there's moments of
silence
moments of silence what time is it okay
smoke weed six hours a day 20 days a
week
end soon uh let's see yes thank you
hashem
i'm telling you right there that's what
you're talking about give credit to
james newton howard
howard katrina back in here thank you
buddy have you read
amaldan comics crossover of marvel and
dc
comics with heroes like mix of batman
and wolverine superman captain america
iron man green lantern etc is the film
version possible
well i haven't heard of amalgam comics
i've heard of like crossovers like this
but maybe they stem from there
um it's not possible yet but when disney
officially buys the dc
universe after that max fails to
successfully pull off engaging people
says hbo maxine's again nothing but crap
now
and i'm what it's yeah i'm fine with hbo
max but everything i'm hearing about is
like is this really seem like it's worth
it
because hbo max hbo now was already
basically what hdmi max is mine is a
couple of original pieces
yeah so i'm thinking maybe it may be uh
i don't know i mean i don't think we'll
see it in
our lifetime honestly actually
our lifetime would be the best time to
do it i could see it in our lifetime i
don't necessarily see it like within the
next
decade or two oh no oh god no two or
three
two or three decades down the road like
i feel like partly
it'll take the mcu truly falling from
grace
uh uh and that'll just be the first it's
not gonna lead to it directly but it'll
be the first part is they have to really
need to do something out there you wanna
know
when we'll see superman aversing
um [ __ ] like wolverine where dc
versus marvel in the movies
here's what it's going to be when we
need a goddamn
jurassic world indominus rex
there's going to be [ __ ] uh like in
jurassic world although people are bored
of dinosaurs we need a [ __ ] hybrid to
spice it up
when superhero movies officially reach
that spielberg cap that we heard about
forever ago and it still hasn't gotten
there
when when that happens then they're
gonna be like we need to
find a way to bring audiences back and
then they're gonna do that
with their indominus rex will be dc
versus marvel in a live action format
that's what it's going to be
yeah or maybe we'll just get the uh you
know marvel vs capcom movie
i mean that'd be also really cool do it
oh my god think of it as like an
elseworlds thing where like all these
characters are abducted in this
holy fighting tournament by a creature
you know more powerful than they
where's my paycheck hollywood junkie xl
did do the score for amazing spider-man
2 as well
and mad max fury road what thank you
anisa what operating system is most
popular in the marvel universe she has
the answer right here
van os i
like it you're so sweet oh my god you're
going to be a great mom one day
you got the dad jokes to be a terrific
oh my god that's what all the super
chats turn into were all these questions
and
all these like joke answers yeah finally
oh my god finally someone's brought it
up
yes dread 2012 my favorite comic book in
action film till
date yes that is [ __ ] uh
you know alex garland pretty much
directed that it was like the the zack
snyder joss whedon situation in some
ways except really alex garland did not
get the credit he deserved oh wow i
didn't i knew he wrote it i didn't
really like peter
travis or some travos something like
that who directed it um
yeah i feel like i don't know exactly
but i feel like the director had some
kind of a claim for
for those like really really hyper frame
rate camera
things and that's how that happened yeah
something but yeah i didn't realize that
there was a whole directorial thing
there yeah man uh
[ __ ] uh yeah alex garland did a lot
of the directing for i didn't get the
credit he deserved
um but yeah dredd is like honestly i
like judge dredd the sylvester stallone
rob schneider movie i actually like that
one
uh i think it's a i think it's a really
really a lot of fun
the name of judge dredd's gun the law
oh john john peacemaker oh yeah
stormbreaker um no i i think
but dredd is dread surprise dread had
there's not been much talks
there's been talks of making a mega city
one show
but that i'm surprised that hasn't come
back because for a hot minute the the
dread sequel petitioners were you know
almost
making headway there was like a minute
where carl urban was back in talks or
something
but i feel like that would be that would
be a truly
like triumphant moment if they could get
a dread suit yeah because that's like an
underrated and
and you know a lot of people you know
obviously think that's
like a great underrated you know comic
book adaptation that got overshadowed by
the raid at the time i just wish that
slo-mo drug was real
in dread yay
i would be taking it all the time and
that's how i would be doing reactions
i've absorbed every frame and now i will
break down this black widow trailer for
you
frame by fray and you would get the most
like
dense qualitative physical reactions
yeah just because you were taking it in
on such a deep level
uh where are we out here oh my god eric
horseman's getting in on the jokes now
oh no thank you eric where's the best
place to find out about
spider-man
[Laughter]
oh nowhere to go oh yes
i love that book i love that a comic
book
brendan v i see you in our chat dude
what uh
how are you doing brandon is everything
we were talking on instagram
are you okay buddy you doing all right
uh let's see
all right oh my god what is the hulk's
favorite
song it's gotta be something by smashing
pumps oh is this smashy pumpkins yeah
um is there another smash song
or something about being green oh it's
not easy being green
is that it it could be yeah i don't know
ah
let's just see here let me see if we got
it it's gonna be oh you got it it's not
easy being grand we work together
make sure to bookmark all these jokes
write them down somewhere okay
rhys francis all right
let me see here oh my god all right
where do most superheroes live
i love how this is what our live streams
turn into
uh where do most superheroes live caves
in the hearts of millions
[Music]
that's a great that's a pun and a
geography lesson
um let's see you know i'm really in the
mood to watch thor ragnarok right now
i'm really in the mood to watch the dark
world
i think i think i've just it's imprinted
on me from looking at this the whole
time
it's uh yeah it's a very alluring movie
i feel like that's an easy
like is i would love to rank the mcu
movies on on
like how much you crave to watch them
you know what's weird to me is like what
i'm thinking about
like the basic just the batman ser the
batman live action franchise i'd want to
see
done in movies is really simple you
start with young batman you get your
villains in there you do about eight
movies
and then you get old man batman and then
you build up to an
arkham asylum movie i always i don't
know how why no one's thought about it i
always
wanted to just [ __ ] i mean i know in the
arkham asylum story it's not
young batman but it would be a really
cool like culmination film
yeah if you had like a ubilitum arkham
asylum movie
you build up all the villains and like
oh my god how cool would that be guys
yeah
with the way these universes work i
almost feel and
and because the villains drive these
franchises in a lot of ways i feel like
if you made the arkham asylum the way
station for
this universe you could yeah open up a
lot of mobility
you know all right here we go what do
you guys thank you eric horseman what do
you guys get if you cross captain
america with the incredible hulk
uh the incredible
america steve banner
stephen tyler the star space spangled
banner
oh oh oh oh
and an anissa shout out you are you
created a monster anissa
dude that was good do we get hurley's
joke
or we or we spaced him out thor's face
oh no [ __ ] where'd it go
it's just up there yeah there we go who
is thor's favorite singer
yes that was amazing that is great yeah
that is meant to be you should write for
dave chappelle
um i see a lot of people dude brendan v
man you
mean thank you i appreciate that dude
sam raimi spider-man definitely
that's her favorite one spider-man 2 is
my favorite one but brendan how are you
doing
um i don't want to get into like you
know i mean oh actually i see you
brought it up here in the chat
but brendan's boyfriend right now is um
he's currently on life support so if you
can send as much positive love and
prayers his way please do so
uh yeah i mean you don't have to you
don't want the super chat
you need all the resources you have
right now yeah uh but
i i'm glad you're i'm glad to have you
here and you know go back a little bit
because we're actually gonna end soon
glad we share the spiderman love uh
which again just today i saw another i
think warren
posted another video about uh toby
maguire's coming let's help himself
multiverse or whatever
one ryan beatty one of our top patrons
here contributed a lot of super chat
today i was into my car in this book
says to me can you give me a lift i said
sure you look great the world's your
oyster
go for it that's clever
[Music]
kaltur turex oh my god you know i gotta
say i saw the word pop tart
i my mother for some reason
has been giving me a bunch of pop tarts
like
it's like the most random thing every
time i see her i get
pop tarts from her they're a classic
they [ __ ] love pop
they're they're so great
last one i always decide when i see that
pop-tart commercial until i realize it
is not john you guys must already
what is this what's popcorn this is
someone's this is the only like that
you're
not the first person to bring this up
what is this pop-tart commercial i get
random messages all the time like
somebody please send me this commercial
because i want to know like i've been
i i've been told i'm the guy from blind
wave i know who he is
like yeah i love pop tarts so i feel
like if i'm not
being compensated for this commercial
i'm angry
i remember one time i think it was
comic-con
some guy reckoned i knew this guy was
full of [ __ ]
all right so some guy at comic-con
recognized
me and was like ryan right i'm a big fan
of your channel
and at this point i've already been greg
alba for a few years yeah and he looked
at johnny he's like hey you're that guy
from blind wave
you're not a big fan of this channel
john and i haven't partnered up
officially on the show for like two
years at this point
i am that guy from blind wave that's the
secret
oh uh rizzo gaming oh he's got another
one here i was stealing things in the
supermarket today while
balance on the shoulders of vampires i
was charged with shoplifting
on three counts oh john showing that pit
sweat
yes i must be stressed out
look at that pit sweat yeah compared to
mine
you got the fan right next to you too
well yeah extremely blowing into the
table
but you're way closer to the fan than i
am there we go now i feel uh
several degrees hydrated i've been
drinking this water
all day uh all right
okay here's the update about brandon
me's boyfriend seriously don't
no more got a positive update today he's
responding following commands and it
decreases auction level thanks guys
that's [ __ ] here right because this
whole week it just seemed like it was
getting worse and i'm glad to hear that
he's doing better
thank [ __ ] goodness i'm so glad to
hear that what's your boyfriend's name
by the way
you just messaged me no need to
to tip oh here we go yes yes you're
getting it jacob that's been my idea
you must feel so vindicated my idea was
to do an eighth film that was my idea uh
i've told time about this before
start with young batman and the rock
there would already be a dick grayson
established in mine and there would and
uh he's already in the nightwing venture
of his life
and and the robin that would be
introduced would be uh tim drake
and then by the time you get to the
eighth batman film that's an arkham
asylum he gets help from the bat family
and so you get nightwing in there you
get robin in there you get batgirl in
there you get ruby roasted we're turning
up
yeah whereas batwoman yeah
i can't wait for 10 hours to pass and us
to get the actual story about yeah but
no thank you jacob because i
i wanted to build up to the bat family
in arc
but also borrow the arkham asylum
storyline the more i hear
your idea for this i hope that someday
you you can realize it
[ __ ] will i believe in you
i do uh let's see toasters
wow that's surprising to hear wow
brandon v i mean have you ever had a
toaster strudel
you've got to look out for your
boyfriend steven though yes i
i need to yeah the toasters through
commercials always looked good but i've
never been in
those so i can't it would be a conflict
of interest um but yeah guys
all right uh so my girlfriend uh she
just got back
from a protest that was going on in
downtown l.a got pretty out of hand
and because of like things getting set
on fire uh she was ex like she came back
in
and it's just you gotta be pretty rattle
smoke
uh so yeah and uh so i wanna go
uh uh we have to we're usually we go to
like the three hour mark today we're
gonna end it right around
here i appreciate everyone being here
but i do want to uh
check up on her once again another
reminder anissa it's okay that's only
super chat we're ending today anyway
um today did we miss a niece's super
chat
wait wait hold on well we can't miss a
single [ __ ] super chat i think we did
oh no yeah
anissa oh oh wait we did miss one before
we go
why was thor avoiding his brother loki
oh because he wanted to be low-key
about it oh is that good
that might be it what's the answer or is
it
you can just yeah you could just type it
uh what's
her name just type it in go back up i
think i think i saw
an issa in there just a smudge
a new enzo that wouldn't be super chat
anymore that's not the punch line to the
joke
oh wait a minute oh pop tart commercial
on youtube jonathan van ness 2020 is not
you john but out of the corporate eye it
is i was gonna say
if you had said queer eye then i would
have gotten it yeah jonathan van ness
2020. he's on queer eye i think
jonathan you said yeah it says on
youtube
hold on a sec oh sorry sorry sorry all
right hold on we're gonna we're just
gonna
watch this right now before we go yeah
it's a
free reaction okay it's the one from
four months ago okay
here just turn the volume up oh wait we
can show them it hold on
oh yeah lookie there okay
people keep freaking saying that are you
the guy in the pop tops commercial the
john humphrey
and we have no idea what what they're
talking about
[Music]
to me it's just another generic white
guy with long hair and beard
go ahead say go watch gay of thrones
okay because he's actually really funny
i finally got the [ __ ] answer to that
[ __ ]
yes that is me love you too eric
horseman thank you buddy
and coltar thank thank you for finally
telling us what that was about
anissa we need the answer yeah and i
would be cast as nightwing in greg's
movie yes
yeah yeah absolutely mm-hmm i'd be
alfred
i got the body uh yeah dracu man dracula
is the batman version of breitbart
interesting all right guys well um
thank you thank you guys so much uh for
being here jacob thank you for your
first time being here
uh of course thank you thank you eric
horseman i really appreciate that
uh once again one last reminder uh go to
blacklivesmatter.com today you can
donate over
there and support the minneapolis
protesters as well
exactly there's always keep stay
informed and everything but anissa
we need a [ __ ] answer
but i appreciate the love and support
just the same and the answer to thank
you anis i appreciate it but we need the
answer to the loki joke
good night max redling that's true i am
brown boy i wrote it in the chat
we couldn't see it we looked around can
you write it again
well thank you guys so much thank you
for never know we actually stayed on
topic for the most part
all day today so and that's a rare feat
for us and this is a fun super chat
be safe out there there's a lot going on
in the world right now
so be as safe as you can uh thank you to
all parts of the world that tuned in
today
and uh thank you to everyone who
contributed to our super chat and if you
didn't that's
a okay just thank you for being here and
chiming in
everything's been great with i i this
was a lot of fun
thank you guys from the bottom of my
heart means a lot to be here got a last
of us two video coming out tomorrow
i'll see you guys
you